ladies and gentlemen this clip was
brought to you by ship station and when
you buy ship from me
it's brought to you by ship station 2 so
thank you ship station for delivering
you this clip
i'm a freestyle genius you guys are you
guys are down to do like uh like a
island boy wild ride freestyle i mean we
don't we don't have to put him on the
spot like that no you can well what do
you want what you want to do he's asking
you to come up with a freestyle on the
spot just like a little [ __ ] podcast
that we're doing right now what exactly
do you want
to do
how about uh like you know how about uh
doing a podcast with steve let me let me
know that i'm old and you're young
and that that's better for you
yeah whatever you guys want you want to
do a cappella you want to be steve old
man
i'll just win my doll steelo yeah we
turn them like a [ __ ] [ __ ] is the
island boys in the podcast going fast
with my cash on the dead [ __ ] ain't
nobody gonna stop me may that [ __ ] go
to running i go dummy got some they
gonna do it for me he gonna die he gonna
slide he gonna ride all day long hey
[ __ ]
i say [ __ ] homicide murder season put
it down okay totem up on different
breeding play it down okay
needy riding in the lambo while you see
me while i'm speeding okay
[Music]
[Music]
that money to the top and then i get
some [ __ ] wrecks in yeah
i got so much on my mind and i be
reminiscing about the past yeah
trying to get that money trying to get
them bands here yeah i got sticks i got
sticks we gonna let it go i ain't never
[ __ ] i'm a mama man i'm trying to make
it i ain't worried about no [ __ ] you
could put me in a cell block i was
running [ __ ] i was hitting licks here 13
years old yeah i was in juvenile yeah
direct follow me at 16 i ain't give a
[ __ ] yeah when i came out i was rolling
off a beating [ __ ] i knew i was chosen
hey yeah
hey
[ __ ] i'll pop another perky i be irkin
i be searching i'm like damn i put some
work and i was really in the booth and
i'd be spitting out my
[Music]
up by his top i just don't rap him on my
talk i be freestyling i'm wailing and
i'm talking all my [ __ ] yeah i'm
watching with the grip i got the aol 15
yeah it's talking two through threes and
i'ma watch that just because
i like
um very girl i like taking perkies i
like hurting
chest pain through the night yeah
shining light yeah baby growing bright
like a stone yeah let's just go to wall
yay popping danny perkins in that lean
bottle by the
[Music]
just there be some cappers
yeah
that was [ __ ] way good dude
yeah dude
i'm impressed by that i like it me too
we free stuff i mean that was fire yeah
we freestyle all the time we like we
just we just know how to rap dude if you
haven't figured out that in this day and
age everybody can have their own
thriving business selling stuff online
then it's time for you to figure out
ship station because that is what makes
it possible that's how i'm selling so
many of these awesome autographed bee
skateboards because dude ship station
gives you access to the best shipping
rates which are normally reserved for
like fortune 500 companies i'm talking
every carrier us post office ups dhl
whatever it is man it's all integrated
into one system and it doesn't matter if
your business is using amazon etsy your
own website whatever it is it is the
most simple interface where everything
is just made super easy
and
get this you can have a 60-day free
trial absolutely free if you go to
shipstation.com and then you click the
microphone in the top right hand corner
type in the promo code stevo and that's
right you got 60 days that's two months
of totally stress-free
shipping with the best rates and i'm
telling you your business can take off
just like mine did so make ship happen
get your ecommerce game thriving with
shipstation one more time it's
shipstation.com
click the microphone in the top right
corner use the promo code stevo and 60
days absolutely free and you can become
a budding businessman